There are two different kinds
of in-game currency you can
use to purchase in-app items,
soft currency and hard currency.
Soft currency is easy to get and
is often used to pay for
consumables, whereas hard currency
is more difficult to get and
is used to get rare items or
entitlements.
Soft currency is easy to get
because it's very grindable.
And grindable just means that you can
play parts of the game like levels or
mini games over and
over again to accumulate soft currency.
So the more time you
spend playing a game,
the more soft currency
you slowly accumulate.
One example of this is
Fruit Ninja's starfruit currency.
Players accumulate starfruit
over time as they play the game.
And once they save up enough, they can
use these starfruits to buy consumables
like bomb deflects or game power-ups.
Hard currency is between real money and
soft currency.
It's difficult to earn and can also
usually be bought with real money.
Like we mentioned before,
it's often used to pay for
entitlements or other rare items.
In Fruit Ninja golden
apples are hard currency.
You can only earn them by
paying real money for them or
by watching offer wall adds.
These apples are used to unlock
levels in tournament challenges.
So if you want a fun
multiplayer challenge,
you'll have to pay hard currency for
that entitlement.
Let's look at some other
examples of in-game currencies.